pink slime is back people I'm not
talking about that goo from ghostbusters
to I'm talking about our beef and the
stuff that has been in McDonald's meat
for a long time let's take a little look
at it yeah that is the ammonia laced
by-product when they take all the
crappiest meat the parts that are left
over because they want to give you the
cheapest crap to eat and your burger and
it's literally not fit for human
consumption
and then they spray it with ammonia and
then they somehow transform it back into
something that actually is edible we did
a story on it a couple weeks ago Jamie
Oliver did some great work to expose
this McDonald's is not gonna use it
anymore which I suppose is nice what
we'll put a little annotation to our
video about it up there but pink slime
is actually returning even though
McDonald's is giving it up I cannot
believe this
four more states just this week have put
aside the concerns of pink slime and
they are resuming to buy the
controversial product I don't think I
said that grammatically right that means
seven states in total are now gonna have
the pink slime meet this is Illinois
Pennsylvania Virginia Texas Iowa
Nebraska and North Dakota and on top of
this as if we're not having enough meat
problems in the United States the USDA
just approved Chinese poultry can now be
shipped into the United States for
consumption even though it China has all
kinds of food problems and other
diseases and all kinds of other stuff so
sometimes it seems like we're taking a
step forward with this food stuff and
you hear about eating healthy all the
time and we expose pink slime in one way
and then people get upset and don't want
to eat it anymore and then suddenly the
USDA Jeff Smith oh yeah four more states
let's go back to the pink slime what
what what is it that we love about pink
slime I this is so disgusting I can't
even
I just love that even with the China the
the US inspectors there's there's going
to be no inspectors they're just like I
mean am I correct in that article where
we're sending chickens the u.s. is
sending chickens to China they processed
the chicken make it into nuggets or
whatever you all whatever you all they
do pink slime a chicken by the way then
they ship it back to the US we buy it
and eat it yeah that's what's happening
people don't realize like the crazy
system of our food even even at Trader
Joe's which I always feel like I'm doing
something good for the earth when I eat
there I know that doesn't make any sense
when you buy a package of burger meat at
trade Rios it comes from four countries
that means that they have the meat in
four different countries and then they
just kill it all here I guess yeah and
then we and then we eat it they don't do
pink slime though I don't know why
anyone eats meat and I really like these
stories are so I highlight the the pink
the lean finely textured meat is made
from the remnant scraps of cattle
carcasses that were once deemed too
fatty to go into human food yeah I take
that medium-rare he's like wow how could
you possibly order any meat ever again
right so now adding and then when you
add China to the equation you know
they've had outbreaks of avian flu there
was this thing where they were making
chicken jerky and they were killing
thousands of dogs I mean all kinds of
yeah really horrible stuff is this
partly because we don't see we're so
disconnected from our food you know we
don't live on farms anymore it's just
some far-off place and then we get it
packaged and we're like yeah we just see
it there we um it's also byproduct of
what's happened with our economy I don't
want to get into an economic talk but
it's the first thing we care about
you're thinking okay I've got three kids
how can we feed them all yeah okay I got
to make it to this point of week because
this paycheck kind of sucks
so you're thinking whatever's the
cheapest because these are going into
schools is the big part of this next
story we think oh my god they're going
to school schools back okay maybe now
there's a break with look at food prices
or feeding everyone and then so your
school start picking up because they're
not getting any money either because
that's who cares about schools in kids
whatever yeah so then we have that all
of our money goes to other places so the
first thing that as consumers we think
is is it cheaper it's still meat right
it's still coming off of animals right
yeah
they added something to it but the USDA
is declaring this completely safe and
well it's safe let's not label let's not
let anyone know why we say so if it's
just sales
move on yeah I mean they're literally
they're spraying it with ammonia to kill
whatever bacteria is left after they've
taken the worst piece it's not even meat
it genuinely is hate but is this you
know Michelle Obama has done so much
about eating right and staying fit and
we're gonna do a story about about fat
kids in a second but is it a little
bizarre that she hasn't fought this
thing more this sort of outsourcing of
our food it's so yeah well no yet top
roping is fun it's good I can't believe
you're anti jump rope no it just seems
like it feels like it's so extreme like
we have this one everything is like
farm-to-table farm-to-table you know and
like you sit down a restaurant and
you're like where exactly to the cow was
a cow happy with it you know to me
that's so extreme in and you know we are
I am also in a bubble it's like New York
in LA I go back and forth so it's like
every single thing is like you know the
gluten in the clothes you know
everything is so and this is the
calories and this is how fresh it is and
you know what people are spoofing it all
the time and yet that this is America
this is really the majority of what
people are eating and it really does
come back to the money it really does I
mean I think in the article it said
they're getting a little bit net schools
are getting a little bit more money for
like whole grains and stuff like that so
okay so you up your grains but then you
have no money to actually get a real
burger so it's I mean it's it's it's
completely disgusting and ridiculous I
would just spend all the money on for
kids for vegetarian items I there's just
there's no way it all goes back to of
course you know paid off politicians
they need to back certain corporations
that are give them the money that give
them the reason to think they can still
be in office because of our system in
the first place so that's the main
problem but because of that well look at
the criticism that Michelle Obama has
gotten for seeing a get your kids up and
make a move or hasa man how about some
initiatives to do so and that I think
it's that six cents per kid's lunch
they're giving certain schools to give
them fits and vegetables socially yeah
you to work out so man anything right
yes imagine she goes after the the
origins of our meat and our food its
what the hell are you doing yeah you
know and then they're gonna come harder
at
so maybe one thing at a time although
she's gonna run out of time they're
gonna be out of office soon not soon but
before anything is done about this and
it's one thing at a time it's hard to
really tackle them all I'm not sure
that's not create jobs we're taking our
farm and our Agriculture's been this
staple of America we how do we how do we
let this happen you know what I'm saying
like you would think that all these
politicians it would be good business it
would be good politics to keep the food
that we grow in our country it's more
jobs it's it just seems like it's a
win-win situation yet well we save like
we save X amount of money to ship it to
China to ship it back it makes
absolutely no sense well I'm pretty sure
that the reason we do it is because as
much as we love freedom we really love
the freedom to be fat
[Music]